It's the final day of voting but already
Russia's presence is overwhelming here
for anyone doubting the outcome of the
referendum the writing is on the wall
and on the lips of the organizers
[Music]
we invite you to the referendum on
joining the Russian Federation please
come in for voting happy holiday to you
the mood was upbeat at this polling
station
for the pro-russian leaders here in
eastern Ukraine this day was meant to be
a historic event
I'm voting in favor of joining the
Russian Federation
I'm giving my vote for a happy bright
future for us as part of the Russian
Federation for a happy and bright future
for our children our grandchildren our
descendants
I'll show you too
foreign
means a large chunk of Ukraine will
become Russia at least in the kremlin's
eyes
of course today amid the special
military operation and referendums in
the donbass saving people in all
territories where the referendum is held
is at top of the mind and in the center
of the attention for our entire Society
in our country this is natural because
it's connected with traumatic events in
preparation for those dramatic events
Russia is sending an additional 300 000
reservists to the front line
guys how do you feel wonderful
of course it can't be any other way
everything will be fine everything is
okay how's the mood we are in the mood
for fighting but not everyone is happy
this mother argues with a Russian
official in nalchik a city near the
border with Georgia
I will speak out I am right we are the
occupiers Ukraine has not been part of
the USSR for a long time
but the Russian government remains
determined this is defense minister
Sergey shoigu visiting a training camp
for recently mobilized troops and it's
these men that President Putin is now
relying on to win his War
Muhammad Al Jazeera Moscow